hi this is melody and welcome to my glow
cover photo shoot I always tried to keep
the vibe on set very light and fun and I
try to keep everybody in a good mood
even though she keeps it light Mary
Pierre admits a converse shoe comes with
added pressure I think that went that's
when I perform the best I think that's
fun I love doing covers I've always been
obsessed with beauty looks and makeup
since a very young age on top of burning
up the page and tearing up the small
screen the hockey wives star is also
blowing up on social media
I think that social media is such a huge
part of what we do now you can't just be
a TV host or an actress you're kind of
your own company now and social media is
the direct connection with the audience
part of the image she shares with that
audience is her unique style with
Patrick my stylists there's no rules
we hate rules and we hate being put in a
box and when we feel like nobody would
expect me in this type of dress or this
type of outfit that's exactly where we
go for so what would it take to get a
rise out of hockey husband Brandon Prust
you have to go naked to kind of like do
a statement and be like Oh baby by the
way I shot naked well the second black
one that you got you can try on not the
first one but he likes fashion he loves
it and I think he has an eye for photos
as well
so when he flips the pages always like
that's a good shot of you and that's not
a good one
sound like thank you he's a good judge
catch Mary Pierre on the cover of glow
magazine on newsstands now